Now we'll discuss Judaism in the right
perspective to understand
the concept of God in Judaism.
It's mentioned in the Old Testament in
the book of Deuteronomy
chapter number 6 verse number four.
Moses peace be upon him says
it's a Hebrew quotation which means y
Israel the lord our god is one lord
it's mentioned in the book of Isaiah
chapter number 43 verse number 11 I even
I am lord and besides me there is no
savior
it's mentioned in the book of Isaiah
chapter number 45 verse number
I am Lord and there is none else. There
is no God besides me. It's mentioned in
the book of Isaiah chapter number 46
verse number 9. I am God and there's
none like me. It further mentioned in
the book of Exodus chapter number 20
verse number 3 to 5. Thou shalt have no
other gods before me. Thou shalt not
make unto thee any grim, any graven
image of anything of any likeness in
heaven above, in the earth beneath, in
the water under the earth. Thou shall
not b onto them, nor serve them. For I,
thy God, thy Lord is a jealous God.
The same message is repeated in the book
of Deuteronomy chapter number 5 verse
number 7-9
where it says thou shalt have no other
god besides me. Thou shalt have no other
gods before me. Thou shalt not make unto
thee any graven image of anything of any
likeness in the heaven above, in the
earth beneath, in the water beneath the
earth. Thou shall not bow onto them nor
serve them. For I, thy God, thy Lord is
a jealous God. So if you read the
scriptures of Judaism, if you read the
Old Testament, if you read the Torah,
you shall understand the concept of God
in Judaism and understand Judaism in the
right perspective.